and staying with the uk and britain is
due to begin its rollout of the world's
first coronavirus immunizations using
the biontech pfizer vaccine today
it's being called v-day in britain and
it's hoped the vaccine will mark
the beginning of the end in the war
against the virus
this is a moment the whole world's been
waiting for
the uk is the first to roll out the
bioentec pfizer
covid19 vaccine it's a momentous moment
for a population with the highest death
toll in europe
and offers a window of hope for the
future
we've very very sadly lost many
residents
of those care homes who've died from
covid it's been a hugely
challenging and difficult year and and
all the time
uh this promise and this hope of a
vaccine has been there so it's very
exciting to have got to the point where
it feels like that we might be able to
make a really
positive step forward with the help of
the vaccine
the uk health service is calling this
the biggest immunization program in its
history
first in line for the vaccine will be
people over 80 as well as care home
staff
and frontline healthcare workers but
this rollout poses major logistical
challenges
this vaccine needs to be stored at
around minus 70 degrees celsius
and moved carefully meaning in england
it will at first
only be administered from 50 specific
hospital hubs
for the majority of the public here
vaccinations at sites like
this hospital are still a way off
but for authorities in the uk the
messaging surrounding the start of this
rollout could not be
more important after all approving the
vaccine is one thing
actually encouraging people to take it
is quite another
as the first in the world to authorize
the vaccine the uk
is dependent on public trust and
enthusiasm
isn't universal the risk is what the
long term effects but against it
i would take it because the benefits
outweigh the risks
seems a sensible thing to do yeah and
it's the only way we're going to get out
of the pandemic
i think it's very very fast how it's
come out um
but i trust it i ain't taking it i i've
done my research
and the vat scene yeah
uh so basically it's like a chip where
have you um researched your concerns
uh youtube and facebook uptake of the
vaccine will be key to its success
and authorities are being advised to
find creative ways to address public
concern
and tackle misinformation there's some
speculation the queen may even reveal
she's had the vaccine to boost
confidence
it is extremely important that these
people get the vaccine
so we need to find a way how to
communicate it to them and how to
in a way isolate them from these
damaging examples of misinformation that
they're seeing
on social media and i think it is the
role for the health providers it is a
role for the community leaders
to actually go out there and try to
explain to them
that what are they seeing on social
media is actually
not always the truth the eyes of the
world are on the uk this week
with governments keen to see not just
how it tackles the logistical challenges
but how it sells this vaccine to a
public being asked to keep
pace with science